en las últimas horas da la sensación que
se está acelerando la escalada de
tensión podríamos estar cerca del inicio
de una guerra
podemos decir que ya se ha iniciado pero
putin lo está haciendo vamos a decir
como en cámara lenta no de un solo golpe
de un solo tirón trata de invadir todo
ucrania yo considero que es lo que
pretende e invadir toda ucrania pero
está empezando por esas dos regiones
esto es como un show que lo han
organizado
primero se declaran independientes las
llamadas repúblicas populares de
audiencia de lugares que ellos crearon
entonces ahora solicitan ayuda acusando
a ucrania de verdad atacados son
realmente falsos positivos por parte de
las fuerzas rusas y regulares están allí
en esas dos repúblicas vamos a decir que
moscú acaba de reconocer esa es la
excusa para que vengan no sb a vista la
historia como por ejemplo cuando invade
stalin
a lituania letonia estonia pues miembros
del partido comunista esa república
solicitaba de asistencia a stalin bueno
ahora esta república solicita apoyo a
putin última entrar con sus fuerzas y
como estas supuestas repúblicas
y pretenden controlar también el
territorio que ucrania controla de esas
dos provincias donde es el lugar pues
tratarán probablemente de empezar por
allí la invasión ocupando liberando esos
territorios de esas dos repúblicas que
pudieran reconocido y eventualmente
habrá un referéndum en el cual todos
votarán para unirse a rusia estas
fuerzas prorrusas han pedido también
diálogo hace lenski algo que el
presidente ucraniano se ha negado en
otras ocasiones podría saber responder a
este llamado podría darse el diálogo
entre las repúblicas y el presidente de
ucrania
realmente no creo porque esa república
obedecen al kremlin a moscú y lo que
pretende es el ens quiera hablar
directamente con quien considera que es
el que les da órdenes a los de donges y
de lugares rebeldes y parece que putin
rehúsa conversaciones así que si hubiera
una buena fe sería de parte de rusia que
es la que le ha quitado el territorio
con fuerzas irregulares y allí se podría
iniciar algo pero ya ha dicho y que los
acuerdos de minsk no tienen razón alguna
porque se han declarado independientes
según el estado república y que ya rusia
les ha reconocido como tal por lo tanto
los acuerdos de minsk ya no tienen razón
de ser realmente y sería simplemente una
cuestión de entretener a los ucranianos
mientras rusia se prepara para una
invasión quizá por otros frentes
mientras supuestamente estaría
conversando con estos grupos pero no
olviden estos grupos están atacando a
los ucranianos o sea que quieren
conversar pero al mismo tiempo
bombardean la defensa de ucrania